the first five were all kind of like
just like
good and tasty and like somewhat hot
that's a different
okay um movies
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we close out
season 12 with joseph gordon-levitt
he's the actor director and producer you
know from films like 500 days of summer
5050 inception and many more
he also stars alongside jamie foxx and
project power which is available on
netflix now
joseph gordon-levitt welcome to the show
thanks man thanks for having me
how are you around the spicy stuff are
you a hot sauce guy
i like some flavor like i like a hot
sauce when it has flavor i don't like
just gratuitous heat for no reason which
i have a feeling some of this might be
but if it's flavorful you know i'm into
[Music]
it
by the way i don't know if you know
there's a heatwave here in southern
california
it's already way too hot for my air
conditioning to handle
and i haven't started eating this at all
all right gonna be a sauna in that room
i'm already sweating i don't know if you
can tell but i did this pretty good and
and like serious should i do an insert
shot with my phone
that's delicious that like i would
definitely eat that all day
so you are very much ahead of the curve
when it comes to hollywood stars on
youtube launching a channel for your
production company hitrecord.org more
than 13 years ago
when the platform's biggest claims to
fame were fred and charlie bit my finger
did you feel like you were breaking
ground on the next big thing back then
or is youtube's evolution and explosion
popularity surprised you
i mean i i wouldn't claim to be so
prescient or anything but
uh yeah i figured a good long time ago
that the internet was gonna be a thing
an important thing i find youtube
incredibly beautiful
my kids were like interested in what
makes fruit go rotten
we found a channel on youtube that's
just nothing but
fairy elaborate stop-motion footage of
all kinds of fruit and food going rotten
i wouldn't be able to
show my kids a video of something so
incredibly specific before
youtube and not to mention just like oh
i want to hear that debussy piece
play it on you know a banjo like you can
just find everything
not to mention like you know idiots like
me eating
too spicy food but the heart and the
soul and the good sides of what youtube
is
is gonna like move past the attention
economy eventually we just have to sort
of course correct and make it so that
uh it's not sort of this behavior
modification technique big data machine
learning
you know extremist tendencies that that
are dominating but i don't think
i don't think youtube has to be that i
think youtube like has
has it within itself to just be the good
stuff
[Music]
are you a cook how did you get this job
no i just do interviews like for us
we were just trying to solve for a
problem we're like how do we make
celebrity interview shows more
interesting
and then this was like the disruptive
element you know you definitely did
you did it that's delicious that's a
super good one
i like both of them so far like i would
i'll protect my pantry and
eat them so something that really sets
you apart as an
actor is your relentless dedication and
my favorite example of that is the years
that you spent
training as a clown under slava palunen
for his off-broadway production of
slava's snow show
how would you sell the traditional
russian art of clowning to people who
only know it from like birthday parties
in the circus
wow i'm surprised i'm very impressed
you're asking me about this this is like
this is a deep passion of mine that i
like don't really talk about and then i
get to go on stage with these clowns and
no one knows it's me
if you're a fan of charlie chaplin but
you watch some of his
movies that are a little less slapstick
and a little more sad
that's what the russians are kind of
like except it's not black and white
it's like the psychedelic color scheme
of a terry gilliam movie
um but sort of charlie chaplin acting
it's very very
real it's very heartfelt it's not at all
about like
it's they they this is what i love about
them they give
performances that i know it might sound
strange but
because they can dress up as something
other than just a normal human
it somehow liberates them i think to
just put their deepest most like
down inside their feelings out
i've been on stage on broadway with them
i've been on stage a couple different
theaters in france with them
it's brilliant how did you find out that
i know about it they're like i love this
thing i love the clowns it's really
funny that you know about this
whoa that's interesting i like that this
is
super delicious so far three for three
yeah enjoy that while you can here
okay so i know that you're a die-hard
francophile and even took a break from
acting so that you could study french
literature at columbia university
paris has long beckoned america's
misfits and artists who want to live the
floor lifestyle and the birthplace of
the enlightenment
but do you think that maybe the mystique
of an american in paris has faded over
the years like if he were alive today
and in his 20s
do you think hemingway would move to
paris no probably not
i mean there's definitely still
something in paris
for people who love movies there's no
other city in the world
that has such a love and like a
a rich like deep love for movies
you can go to a movie theater that's
playing bogdanovich's paper
moon on a wednesday afternoon and
there'll be
30 other french people there but yeah
would hemingway go i don't know
i don't know where bohemia is anymore
yeah did we lose it
you might just kind of have to turn off
your phone and there it is i mean no one
knows about it
no one will know that you found it
that's maybe where you find bohemia
can you recommend a french film or
accessible piece of french literature
that maybe the audience should check out
during quarantine
man this is such a sweet i i expected
this to be like snarky and ironic this
is such like a sweet good-hearted nice
and like enlightening interview um well
i'm happy that we could surprise today
let's see i mean like if you want
something really weird
and frenchy like watch alphaville that's
like a
very strange sci-fi kind of movie
a more recent very weird french movie
there's um
kahax kahalax is um uh
holy motors uh that's a
very weird and very cool movie
[Music]
hotter than l oh the grim reaper
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
whoa i mean we're supposed to be doing
this right
it's been anarchy in the quarantine
episodes
son your podcast creative processing you
interview creative people that you
admire and i found that your discussion
with casting director mary vernou was
really fascinating
do you have a moment in your life a
moment in your career that you would
describe as auditioning rock bottom
well i don't want to you know disclose
who was
hurtful but they're they're definitely
like i've auditioned for
like one director in particular i'm not
gonna say who it is though
sorry but like i admired
uh him a lot like he made uh he this was
it was only for his like third movie he
was making and um
his first two movies i was like i loved
so much
i went in and you know was doing the
scene and he
stopped me in the middle which is like
it's best if you can let the actor
finish the scene before you give them
feedback
stops me in the middle i'm just some
loops yeah i just don't just don't
really buy it
just completely generic useless
dismissive
kind of hateful there's there's
something that's like i hate you that's
basically saying
like i hate you and i i think you're
terrible at this
um and uh and that was it and
but before i went i i had told myself
that i was gonna tell him
how much his movies meant to me i had i
had made
that agreement with myself before
entering the room before everything had
started going so badly
and so before i left as i was like
walking out i was like i just wanted to
tell you
you know how much i love the movies and
how much they meant to me and he goes
um i buy that even less
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you guy i'm not going to say your
name he probably doesn't even remember
that
all right joseph we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
graham where we do a deep dive on our
guests instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so i'll
show you the picture
you just tell us the bigger story and
first things first
last month you posted this 10-year
tribute to inception
what do you remember about the unique
mechanics of shooting in a 100-foot long
rotating corridor for that legendary
hallway scene
oh that was just the most fun there were
a few different ways that it was shot
there was the rotating one but then
there was also like there were
parts on wires they built a long
horizontal corridor then they built this
like 10 story
tower which looked like a hallway
but the floor was a wall and they would
point the camera
up like that way so it looked like it
was shooting
on you know just down a hallway but it
was actually shooting
up a 10 story tower but the most fun was
the rotating one because you didn't have
any harness on you you were just like
free to to be in this in this crazy it
was really
it was like a dream uh i had so much fun
doing that
and then finally i know that you're a
star wars super fan
when we had john boyega on the show he
made some waves for saying that anakin
skywalker is a much more powerful jedi
than rey
where do you stand on the strongest most
powerful jedi
in the star wars saga yoda look i
i'm not the kind of star wars fan that
can like back up my claim with evidence
i haven't read the novels i you know i'm
not on the wiki pages
you know i actually i haven't even seen
the mandalorian um
but just for my subjective
loving perspective and fandom of star
wars
obviously yoda obviously yoga
oh now it's hot that's all right that
hurts
i've been holding off on the milk mama
do it now
seafire gourmet reaper hot sauce
um
it's smoky that one they roast the chili
and you can really kind of taste that
that fire in there
yeah you can change that as someone who
seems especially interested in immersive
technologies
what are the filmmaking innovations you
get most excited about when you think
about movies in the future
um that's hot okay
i feel that be careful be careful on the
pores be careful on the pores
[Music]
it didn't hit me at first it was just
smoky and delicious
really good flavor and it
yeah that's okay okay
i admit i was getting cocky i was like
these are all just tasty
i could see it i could see it i could
see it in you
you warned me you said careful on the
back half and you didn't listen to me
you didn't listen to me i thought it was
gonna be like the first one's level one
then oh
[ __ ] it's really hot
the first five were all kind of like
just like good and tasty and like
somewhat hot that's a different
[Music]
okay um movies
the future of storytelling it's gonna be
it's gonna be video games i don't think
it's gonna really be filmmakers who
figure out how to do
that but it does it feels like kind of
the most
groundbreaking story careful around your
eyes careful around your eyes
oh thanks yeah yeah i don't want to get
chilly in my eyes
but like storytelling that's that's
completely in a whole different
realm than anything we've seen before
i don't think it's gonna necessarily be
the feature film
form
that one that one taught me a lesson
thank you for the warning
you're very kind we want it to be the
the most comfortable least comfortable
interview at the end of the day you know
i thought you just wanted me to be in as
much pain as possible because that's
what the people want to see
we want you to lean into it just a
little bit maybe
oh [ __ ] okay that was
a slightly less aggressive pour but
still like it's on there for sure
that's very aggressive be careful with
that even even your sort of uh foot off
the gas pores are
pedal to the metal pores okay should i
wipe some off
yeah yeah yeah okay
thanks got you got you
um yeah i already feel it
immediately yeah that's that's that's
that he that's just like
remember i said earlier i was like
they're just they're just eat like i
don't feel a flavor
okay what's the holy grail of your magic
the gathering card collection
the most uh the most valuable ones
money-wise are i have real moxes i have
beta moxes
the time walk is my favorite though
probably the one i'm most attached to is
not even all that valuable but it's like
my first rare card that i ever pulled
it's called a nightmare
it's a horse with fire all around it
more swamps you have the more powerful
it is it flies
very appropriate for the situation going
on right now
can you remember the dungeons and
dragons characters that you used to play
with as a kid like which one was the
most creative
fury fury was my biggest one that i
spent the most time on he was um
an assassin he was a dark elf chaotic
evil
really good with daggers my friend nick
next guy was named dark image and mine
was named fury
and we were just horrible killers for
hire and we would just go and kill
kill people all right
we would imagine to kill people speaking
of hyperbolically killing people
are you ready to move on to the next hot
sauce this is the bomb beyond insanity
please be very careful
yeah i can already smell it okay
okay
that one does have some flavor at the
very beginning
fun okay that tastes more like
i'm i'm feeling like a stationary store
like in cleaning products maybe like
the scent of a marker it's like poison
yeah kind of like poison or like like
you know a household item that you
definitely don't want to be
ingesting
sorry folks like i don't you know [ __ ]
on anybody's product but like
i don't have any good reason to eat that
oh don't worry about that everybody who
comes on the show has horrible things to
say about that sauce
really yeah so you've performed a duet
with lady gaga you've wrapped on stage
at madison square garden alongside logic
and i know the music instruments behind
you right now
they're not there just for show pound
for pound what do you think is the best
band t-shirt in your wardrobe
[Laughter]
my friend madison got me an ugly kid joe
t-shirt
parsley because i'm named [ __ ] parsley
because i'm named joe but arsenal
partially because
i'll show partially because
i actually liked that like a couple
songs off that ugly kid joe cd
they did a cover of the cats in the
cradle
which has a dad makes me really sad
ugly kid joe what's your heavy metal
album mount rushmore
um how many heads are on mount rushmore
four
guns and ropes kinda counts as heavier
metal i guess you can put appetite on
there
like careful careful with the eyes
careful with the eyes thank you thank
you [ __ ] sorry
that's why i use this right yep
uh what else um
uh ride the lightning mastodon the first
mastodon record
rage they're not really metal i don't
know [ __ ] black sabbath and uh
i don't [ __ ] know man metallica and
um
i mean just it's uh ride the lightning
master puppets and justice for all kill
them all there
purely metallica mount rushmore
[Music]
[ __ ] that sauce that was [ __ ]
i want to make sure i don't have any of
the remaining of that whatever the [ __ ]
that was
that uh uh
white out um that i ate before
remember white out like i found though
it kind of like didn't work because if
you like wipe something out it's not
really like you can totally like write
over that next thing you know it's kind
of an imperfect product
you have to have patience yo really
quickly we have to be at gordon in five
minutes so
story time you should put that in the
joe you should put that in the show that
my publicist just came on the zoom it
was like
very quickly we have to be at cordon in
five minutes
thank you all right two more to go how
you doing okay
yeah okay this one yep
i just felt a little um like trembling
in my arms just thought i should know
that
[Music]
okay
[Music]
it's the same [ __ ] [ __ ] this is like
it tastes exactly the same as that one
you lied to me i don't want the smoke
joe i don't want the smoke
do you have a favorite food scene from
your acting resume the diner face-off
and looper stands out off the top of my
head
i got to act with mickey rourke mickey
rourke is one of the great actors
of the 20th century and i got to work
with him in a movie called kill shot
he played a murder and i played a
murderer and there's this one scene
where he's
he's just sitting there eating lasagna
and i'm
like this talkative texas psychopath and
i just don't shut up the whole time
and he never says anything and i'm just
like needling him and needling him and
kneeling him and he's just eating
lasagna
until he shoots me in the face he ate i
think probably like two
pans of lasagna and he made sure to
order it from like his favorite italian
restaurant in town
and he ate all of that lasagna
i admire the hell out of it you should
have him on hot ones
he would be an amazing guest on the show
okay
[Music]
it's behind your milk it's behind my
milk
i got you oh there it is yeah okay oh
it's a weird like color of diarrhea
all right oh sorry this one is your
product i shouldn't it's okay
hey i apologize no we let you we let you
swing how you want to swing here on this
show
okay um i have faith that this is gonna
be good this is gonna
i'm gonna enjoy this but if you don't be
honest about it
i'll be honest about it okay i'm gonna
go hard
these squirts are not helping the uh
diarrhea imagery i'll be honest
okay macaroni in the pot
okay that's a lot that's a lot of hot
sauce it's a lot
cheers cheers
right off the bat there is more flavor
it's like tangy and now here comes oh
okay joseph gordon-levitt here we are at
the end of our spicy chicken wings saga
and we've touched on your many creative
projects both old and new but to close
things out
i just want to talk about sesame street
you're on record as saying that it's
your favorite show of all time and you
called hosting the 50th anniversary
special
one of the highlights of your life so
now with your brain on fire
and your mouth ablaze what is the most
important
life lesson that you ever learned
watching oscar the grouch
elmo big bird in the gang
my favorite episode of sesame street is
the episode where
uh oscar starts an ice cream stand out
of his trash can he's selling cones of
ice cream to people
and he really wants to sell them
spaghetti and meatballs ice cream
and nobody wants it because nobody
thinks that spaghetti and meatballs ice
cream
will be any good
[Music]
and all they ever ask for is strawberry
and they keep asking for strawberry
and he doesn't want to sell them
strawberry he wants to sell him
spaghetti and meatballs ice cream
and he never gives up and he never gives
in and he sells them spaghetti meatballs
ice cream
oscar the grouch is my favorite sesame
street character
i am oscar the grouch oscar the grouch
plays by his own rules joseph gordon
levitt
to top out the wings and close out
season 12
and now all there's left to do but is
roll out the red carpet for you joseph
gordon love it
this camera or this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life
you want to be creative you have
something inside you that tells you you
want to be creative in life
i started this thing a long time ago
called hit record
i know it sounds like i'm plugging my
company i know i never shut up about it
on social media that's all i ever do is
just post about it on social media but
it's something that's really truly dear
to me
if you want to do something creative
today you want to write you want to draw
you want to act you want to make movies
or make music whatever it is you want to
do
it's hard to do it alone and if you want
to do something creative today
come check it out i care about it
probably more than anything else i work
on
thank you great job joe great
job great job
all right joe thank you so much good
luck on cordon i'm definitely tuning in
tonight
thanks so much you guys really
appreciate it see you joe
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement
hot ones truth or dab the game is
finally here baby
what's in the box what's in the box
what's in the box
well the kit comes complete with 250
question cards
and then here's how the game works you
just go around the table
you take turns being the host being the
players
and when you're a player you get asked a
question you have a choice just like in
the show
answer it honestly or suffer the wrath
of the last dab and take a look at this
there's even a mini bottle of the last
dab included i suggest you have napkins
on hand
you have to have some milk on hand and
of course be careful be very
careful around the eyes hot ones truth
or dab the play at home game is
available at shop.firstwe fees.com
heatness.com and amazon play at your own
risk
wings not included
[Music]